Speaker 1: Apparently taking a cue from Donald
Trump starting the homophobic attacks on Ron
DeSantis. Donald Trump Jr. Now went on another
one of these manic rants, this time targeted at
Ron DeSantis. And he basically says the Santos is
terrible in every way that the DeSantis you think
might exist from TV reports doesn't really
exist. This is getting very ugly and it's
only going to get worse. Take a look.
Speaker 3: Here's. That's what it is,
guys. He's owned by the billionaire donors,
100% controlled opposition. Let's see which
way the wind is blowing. Let's see which way
they want me to respond, and I will do it. So
I was hoping for a strong response, but we got a
milquetoast response. We got weaker than most RINO
Republicans. We got a weaker response than a lot
of never-Trump Republicans. And guys, here's the
deal. You can hire influencers to post videos of
you dunking on what was like a hot Twitter take
ten days ago on some moron local reporter. You
can get plenty of people to do that, as Ron has.
But that doesn't make you ready for the
big leagues. If you can understand that
this is a fundamental issue of our time.
Then you're not ready. Then it's not your
time. As even people like Mike Cernovich,
who have been big DeSantis supporters,
just heartbroken that DeSantis doesn't
understand what Soros, Diaz and the Bolsheviks
are going to do to this country.
Speaker 1: The Bolsheviks,
Can you imagine? Listen to this.
Speaker 3: Guy. He also said the U.S. is
blew it today. The only people saying otherwise,
I personally hate Trump or were never Trump in
16. And again, even some of those are coming
out and not just coming out like milquetoast.
They're coming out significantly stronger than
Governor DeSantis. Again, I know when you're ready
for the big leagues. I spent a lot of time with
these guys. I spent a lot of time with this. And
just personally, the image created online by the
paid influencers guys, unfortunately, one on one,
it doesn't exist. And this week made it clear.
Speaker 1: So the best and most accurate sign
that the Trump team sees
the Santos as a real threat
is the amount of attention they have paid to Ron
DeSantis over the last two weeks, in particular,
Trump posting daily on troth Essential about
Ron DeSantis. Trump Starting with the homophobic
smears against Ron DeSantis Don Jr Starting with
the attacks on Ron DeSantis. People associated
with Trump, including Steve Bannon, Mike Pillow
and others going after Ron DeSantis. You go after
those that you believe believe pose a threat to
you. This is why Trump seemingly encouraged Nikki
Haley to run as far as we know and is going
bonkers, attacking Ron DeSantis. He sees him
as a threat, even though I still think it's
important to remember Trump is in a position
of power in the Republican primary. If and when
the indictments come, we will evaluate how that
changes those prospects. But if nothing changes,
this really is Trump's nomination to lose.